now let's talk about tonight's Super
Tuesday primaries let's start with the
Democratic side okay there are far more
delegates at stake tonight and we're not
quite ready for that yet Louis there are
far more delegates at stake tonight
alone Louis really wants to get to these
numbers so we put them up on the screen
for audience all of the primaries to
date combined don't have even nearly the
number of delegates that are available
tonight so Louis from a mathematical
standpoint tonight is huge from a
momentum standpoint the early primaries
have been important but now we're really
getting into the meat of this thing uh
yeah well Super Tuesday day if that's
that's the meat that's the UH the the
the what is it the sirloin the filet how
would you describe bone-in ribeye call
it what you want so Republicans have 11
contest tonight Democrats have 12 uh 11
states plus american samoa's caucus the
American Samoan caucus is we don't
really know much about it there's six
delegates at stake we don't really have
polling not expected to be the
difference-maker so if i'm a louis i
will talk about the 11 states that are
voting tonight let's now look at what
things appear to be shaping up like for
tonight in Alabama Hillary Clinton is up
44 in Arkansas Hillary Clinton is up 25
this is a based on the most recent
polling which admittedly is not that
recent in some of these states in
Colorado Hillary Clinton is up 28 in
Georgia Hillary Clinton is up 36 in
Massachusetts on average Hillary Clinton
is up by five a closed state for burning
in Minnesota Hillary Clinton is up 34 in
Oklahoma Bernie Sanders is up six in
Tennessee and Texas Hillary Clinton is
up by just over 25 points each in his
home state of Vermont kind of I mean
he's from Brooklyn but his home
legislative state of Vermont Bernie
Sanders up a brutal seventy-six percent
reminiscent of the black Norwegian metal
that Louis likes and in Virginia Hillary
Clinton up 23 so Louis these are the
most recent numbers we have Bernie
Sanders again we're speaking soberly and
pragmatically he needs to significantly
over perform the polls in any number of
these compelling primary races to be
mathematically in this thing bye
by 24 hours from now 12 hours from now
even well I think we could pick the
number but uh i would say any number
it's it's disturbing disturbing news for
the Bernie Sanders campaign isn't it if
Bernie Sanders wins only Oklahoma and
Vermont tonight realistically the math
is going to not signal a path for him to
a democratic primary nomination he needs
to over perform tonight and I know that
you know as progressives we have this
idea that hey the the real progressive
the most progressive candidate is going
to find a way to that nomination we have
to be very aware of the fact that if the
if the Sanders supporters and those who
recognize that he is to the left of
Hillary Clinton don't get out and vote
vote tonight in in force right far in
far bigger numbers than what the polling
estimates are suggesting which could
happen that the window is going to begin
to close for Bernie Sanders he has to
win uh he has to have a strong showing
somewhere tonight and just eking out two
wins well Vermont wouldn't be eking out
a win he's up 76 but the delegate count
is just so low there and Oklahoma he's
gotta make things happen tonight but do
we really see him do we expect what
happened to Hillary in South Carolina to
happen to Bernie in any of these states
I mean I think maybe I find that highly
unlikely that it would be that off some
have been hypothesizing that for example
in Massachusetts where anecdotally a
pole here in there has Bernie up but on
average he's down he could end up really
getting out the youth vote in
Massachusetts yeah and doing very well
so there are there examples right we'll
just have to wait and see and we'll have
the numbers tomorrow and we'll see what
the Democratic picture is looking like
at that point the online news world is
getting pretty cluttered with lots of
nonsense there's the so-called news
sites that rewrite news articles and
then there's the website we all know
that we just can't trust so lately i've
been reading smashpipe which is an
online magazine whose goal is to
surprise amuse and tell readers things
they don't already know on a wide range
of topics and current events and culture
smashpipe is less interested in trending
topics than in what's actually going on
and smashpipe has no ads whatsoever
other than the reader generated
classified-ad section and they never
will smashpipe is what happens when you
on a bad day stub your toe on the
miseries and mysteries of life check it
out at